[Music]
mike is starting us off this hour in
buffalo new york hey mike welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi dave hi john thank you very much
thank you
how can we help um so my
parents got divorced about 15 years ago
since then
my mom has been paying for a whole life
policy insurance
plan on my father she's done paying for
it she's offered to
kind of transfer it to me it's a hundred
thousand dollar policy
there's fifty five hundred dollars cash
value at this moment
um i believe the annual premium is about
three thousand dollars
not sure what to do uh
why would you do this
um my wife and i were talking about it
and if we
he's 74 years old so i realize it's kind
of like shorting a stock and talking
about the life of my father but
i if we only we're doing quote unquote
invest
five or ten or fifteen thousand dollars
into it to get
a hundred in the end um seems like it
might be an okay idea
it won't be if he lives 20 years
that's true how's his health if we're
just gonna get cold and short your dad
here
he's 74. he's had diabetes for about 30
years and he's had a double bypass heart
surgery
we're not that close like i hope
so i love him as my father but i you
know they're not that close
uh and you were you would become the
beneficiary
i'm currently the beneficiary oh you
currently are
yeah but she's my mother has decided to
stop paying on it so she's
offering for me to continue me and my
wife or
um just take the cash value now and
do something with it okay
um well i you know
the thing about personal finance
is it involves more than just
mathematical analysis
we have to consider emotions and
relationships
and conscience and morality
and behavior all of those things enter
into
a wise answer to your question
mathematically
i think you might come out yeah
but do you really want to do that i
don't
i don't want to do that yeah i mean
we're joking around a little bit of
being a little bit sarcastic about it
you're shorting your dad or whatever
that kind of thing but
i uh it's just not you know
i don't i don't i don't when i'm 75
years old and i'm on my deathbed
i that i didn't want i don't want that
going across my mind that i did that
i don't think you're doing anything
morally wrong it's just
weird would you agree
yeah i think that's why we're having
yeah a little bit of it feels weird
it feels weird you know why it feels
weird because it's weird and mike what
you're gonna start doing
in your how long have you been married
eight years
okay so you're still uh in a young
marriage what you're gonna start doing
you and your wife are gonna start
counting this hundred thousand dollars
you're gonna start leaning into this
hundred thousand dollars
well we can get this kind of house or we
can not deal with this
oh yeah you're gonna start making life
decisions as though this is a sure thing
and what happens is it's gonna further
press on that relationship with your dad
and i get that it like like dave said i
get that the math may work out you may
make some money on this deal
he said he doesn't have much
relationship with him but it's just the
same i just don't want
i don't i just i
i wouldn't do it and it has nothing to
do with the math i wouldn't either and i
i'm the same way i just did i think you
might win the math argument
but i um i don't think you're at the end
of the
i don't think at the end of your life
you're going to be proud now if my dad
came to me and said
i've had this no still no yeah
i just don't want to short my dad no i i
just
definitely it's just straight up what
we're doing here and it's just that
whether you like him or whether you
don't
right i mean maybe you haven't spoken to
him in 30 years i don't know but it
doesn't matter
i i don't it that's not the it's just
it's i'm not i'm not going to do it
i'm short a stranger no i i wouldn't do
it that's what i'm saying
but again i i might if my dad came to me
and said hey i've been working on this
deal i got a scheme for us but
me and my dad are he's all homicide
detectives he talks about that's just
wrong
no yeah i hung out with your dad the
other day it's still wrong okay
yeah you can't short your old man yeah
even if you don't like him in fact i
would say
especially if you don't like him man you
once you start leaning into spending
that money that's hard to come back from
yeah you can do it if you want but you
called us and asked and
again the answer here is based on the
whatever scarring that this event does
to your conscience
that's causing you to ask the question
and this was leave a scar
and i don't want that scar in your
spirit i love it that's what i'm trying
to avoid